good evening
boulder has suffered a terrible and
horrific mass shooting
today and i want to second what the
chief said about the appreciation for
the local state and federal partners
that have responded to this location
and to help with the investigation this
is not the first mass shooting that
we've had in the state of colorado
and one thing that's happened in
response to each and every one including
today's horrific acts
is the response that we have from law
enforcement partners throughout the
metro area
victim advocates from throughout the
area around
boulder and investigators from local
state
and federal agencies as well as
prosecutors from the u.s attorney's
office
and from my office to ensure that
justice is done
my heart goes out to eric talley's
family
his loved ones and his colleagues he was
by all accounts
one of the outstanding officers of the
boulder police department
and his life was cut far too short as he
responded
to the shooting that was taking place at
king supers
i also want to stress how incredibly
sorry i am
for all the victims who were killed at
king supers
these were people going about their day
doing their food shopping
and their lives were cut abruptly and
tragically short
by the shooter who is now in custody
i promise the victims and the people of
the state of colorado
that we will secure justice and do
everything we must do
to get justice in this case in order for
that to happen
a painstaking investigation is already
underway
both at the crime scene and in
interviews
to make sure that we receive all the
accurate information
once that information is secure we'll be
sharing that with the media and with the
community
i would say that i hope the people of
this country
send the families of the loved ones
their thoughts and prayers
but from my perspective there's more for
us to do than just
give us give them our thoughts and
prayers we're going to go all out
to ensure that the right result is
reached and that's why i'm very grateful
that we do have local state and federal
agencies all responding to this location
here today
to ensure that the investigative
investigation is thorough
and complete and ensures that we reach
justice in this case as i mentioned the
shooter
is currently in custody he was injured
an eye towards the prosecution of that
case we're going to be very careful
about the crime scene and how we go
about this investigation
we owe it to the families of all the
victims each and every one of them
to ensure that justice is done and i
promise you that is our commitment
and we will work tirelessly to get there
i'm going to turn it over to the u.s
attorney matt kirsch who's here on
behalf of the
u.s attorney's office and again i
greatly appreciate the local state and
federal cooperation on this
investigation